今天分享的一个主要的标题
是歌词与心思的差异
这个议题蛮有趣的
为什么
因为在古代不合乐的叫诗
合乐的称之为歌不合乐
就是这个文字不能入月
那这个叫诗尚书
于书里有提到诗言志
歌咏言咏
就是唱的意思
之所以有这样子的区隔
是因为文字的结构限制了音乐的生长
像诗经
它都是四个字
四个字像关关雎鸠在河之洲
窈窕淑女君子好逑
你你要怎么入院
他太完整了
太整齐了
然后五言绝句
屈原律师床前明月光疑似地上霜
举头望明月
低头思故乡
你也不好入月
因为他他的字句不是音乐要的格式
它不够自由
所以呢这些不能入狱的古诗词呢叫做诗
可以入月的
可能像乐府诗
汉赋
或者是说宋词
这些是可以入约的
但可以入位
不代表他一定在当下就有音乐的陪衬
举例来讲
宋词是比较特别的例子
宋词当时他就是宋那个年代的流行音乐
他的音乐的格式的走向
他的节奏就是词牌名的格式
所以现在很多人去重填宋词
他是照他的格式去把文字填进去
那音乐没有音乐
所以你只知道他有节奏感
有个宋词的词牌名的节奏感
但是你听不出音乐所有的格式
就是文字的韵脚的段落
李煜的一首词牌名叫虞美人
他是这样子写的
春花秋月何时了
往事知多少
小楼昨夜又东风
故国不堪回首
月明中
要然玉器应犹在
只是朱颜改
问君能有几多愁
恰似一江春水向东流
文字的断点就是格式
就是宋词的词牌里的格式
当时是可以入月的
他现在已经音乐已经散失了
所以他格式留下来了
所以我刚刚强调的是指这个文字的断点
它的韵脚的格式
这个格式当初是可以入月的
那现在音乐已经没有流传下来
而是格式的结构流传下来
现在的流行音乐反而不太一样了
为什么
因为以前的古诗词就算不能入月
他都能朗诵
因为它有音律
它有平仄
它有韵脚
他是可以朗诵的
那现在的诗词
我口就说我手里面写的就是我平常讲的话
在古代中国并不是这样子
古代中国有个叫文言文的书写形式
叫书面语
文言文的好处是说
不管你居住在大江南北
然后声调方言各异
但是你文章都看得懂
派定都看得懂
这个好处是凝聚了这个民族的向心力
为什么你东北有东北的口音
闽南有闽南语客家话
然后甚至于潮汕
甚至于上海这些语音各异的方言
基本上是不能互相沟通的
纵使在福建这个区块
你讲闽北的福州话跟闽南的厦门话
他是完全听不懂的
我们当初认识一个内地的福建人
我们想说啊
福建人我就跟他讲闽南语
就算他完全听不懂哦
原来他是福州人
你就知道它方言的差异性有多大
但是没有关系
我们有书面语
我们有文言文
文言文的这种书面语的文字魅力
把整个民族凝结在一起
因为你看得懂共同的文字
语音各异
那只是发音的系统
所以我们可以做一个大胆的推测
假设中国早期不是表意的汉字
而是拼音系统
几百年过去了
几千年过去了
每个民族会用自己的方言去拼自己的语言
那基本上你的民族凝结力就很弱了
甚至于很难合在一起
因为像欧洲
它是拼音系统
之前在神圣罗马帝国
它是通行拉丁语
整个欧洲都是拉丁语
但拉丁语仅限于贵族阶层在使用
一般平民百姓还是有他们自己的方言
后来罗马帝国的势力衰萎了
各个种族自己兴起
每个种族用自己的方言去拼自己的语言好
有的有了德语
有了法语
然后有了英语
有了葡萄牙语
再过个几百年
基本上他就不能统一了
因为语言会决定了这个文化的走向
那文化会牵扯到民族的认同感
他就没有归属感了
你的德语的拼音跟我西班牙文差异这么大
我怎么能认同你是跟我在一起的兄弟姐妹呢
就很困难
所以欧洲没有办法
在古代形成一个大一统的帝国
几千年来的延续是不可能的
因为它是拼音的系统
拼音系统你会缺少对文字的认同感
对国家凝聚力必备的一个文字
统一的条件已经丧失了
所以欧洲永远不可能成为一个文化
统一的一个板块
但是中国有可能因为我们的文字是统一的
我们的宿命
把所有的凝聚力
把所有的文化认同感都凝聚起来
汉字就像一张无形的网
把大江南北的人紧紧地联系在一起
所谓天下之势
合久必分
分久必合
中国之所以能够一再的维持大一统
不管朝代如何的更迭
如何的分裂
不是因为有了共同的语言
而是拥有了共同的文字汉字
那现在我们关注的话题回来
我们今天的主标歌词与新诗的差异
这个差异主要有两个区块
第一个区块比较显而易见
这个区块有分三大类
一个就是音乐的辅助
韵脚的使用以及文字的格式
这种差异很好判读
为什么基本上现在的诗歌也就是所谓的新诗
他并不入乐
他没有音乐的辅助
再来他不注重韵脚
甚至于他排斥韵脚
因为他觉得诗
创作上应该有某种程度的自主性跟自由
所以韵脚会约束了文字的一个限制
这当然是某一种观点
并不是完全地
正确通常撕不好
入夜除了韵脚之外
文字的格式很重要
因为现在的诗歌很自由
它可能第一大段有三行
第一行八个字
第二行五个字
第三行六个字好了
然后第二段当然有五行
那第一行三个字
第二行12个字
基本上它就不能变成流行音乐里面的a one
a two b one b two了
他没有被重复入狱的可能性
所有的诗歌跟歌词
这个时候就彻底分家了
再来就是创作者主客观的创作角度
还有创作内容物的一个讯息量
这个诗歌跟歌词也非常地不一样
诗歌的讯息量通常都比较饱满
比较多元
比较丰富
那歌词有时候歌词重复唱的句子很多
讯息量就是爱情
就是恋爱
就是背叛
就是单恋或者是失恋
他的讯息量很少
另外就是创作者自己主客观的角度去创作
这一首
不管是诗歌还是歌词
这个差异性就非常地显著
怎么说呢
第一个通常我们专业的词人作词人
我们创作歌词都是客观的角度
而且是被动的
所有的被动式创作是因为我们有案子接了
有一个电影的主题曲
有一个歌手要发片的那个demo
旋律可能好了给我们
然后要给关键字或给方向
那我们就是接受到这个委托之后
我们就是被动式的写作
我们通常不会先写一首词摆在那里
因为你的词的格式不见得是符合他们需要的
所以通常作词者都是被动式的创作
但是诗人不一样
诗人一旦有什么感伤
一旦有什么情怀要抒发
他就是主动式的创作
因为他不用跟作词者沟通
不用跟歌手沟通
不用跟唱片公司的企划沟通
他创作上面的主动性很强
主观性更强
但文字落笔当下就完成
因为它不需要音乐的辅助
但是词人不一样哦
词人要过好几关
特别是新人
当初我们新人的时候
他笔稿的是很辛苦的
笔稿输了是没有润稿费
也没有底薪的
他就是一首demo
一首旋律发给四五个填词者去比稿
他会给主题
他会给方向
你比稿输了就是零收入
零收入是这样子竞争的
创作的动机很不一样
我们是被动式的创作
是客观式的创作
为什么客观
因为我们是帮一部电影服务
是帮一个戏剧服务
是帮一个歌手服务
一张专辑服务一个城市服务
我们不是帮自己的情感服务
但是诗人他的创作都是替自己的情感服务
所以你可以从诗人的诗句
内容里去窥探他的乡愁
因为他讲的乡愁一定是自己的乡愁
他讲的孤独一定是自己的孤独
他一定是有感而发主动性的创作
但是我们词人不一样啊
我们讲到一个很感伤的恋爱故事
不见得是自己的故事
那就太辛苦了
他历练太多了
爱在线前
我
我不可能去美索不达米亚
或者是前世轮回才写的歌吧
不可能我写了一个上海
1943写完
过了好几年我才去上海
我们是被动式客观的写作
我们服务的对象是唱歌的
是一张专辑
是一个城市
是是一一部电影
我们比较不会服务自己的情感
所以反而因为这样我们的共鸣性很高
因为我们不是主观性的服务自己的情感
我们是客观性的服务他人的情感
反而比较容易切入别人的情感面
打入别人的一个愁绪里面
因为我们是客观式的创作
我是主观式的情绪
这个是所有的诗歌跟歌词
创作上最大的一个差异
以前我们用的是书面语
是文言文
那并不代表我们的老祖宗讲话都有之乎者也哦
不是的
他讲话就像一样有寻常的家常话
在聊天要吃饭干嘛
并不是一定是文章式的那种
之乎者也并不是的
只是说那是书面语
是文章用的
古人可能对于书写在纸张上的一个文字很要求
他肯定要有某种程度的一种仪式感
用文字写成的那些经史子集
他的文字并不是那个时候的人讲话的
直接的语气并不等于这个有好有坏
到近代之后
这样子的书写形式就不合时宜了
为什么教义就不太能普及
因为文言文书写的书面解读的能力比较高
你要再次翻成白话文
我们应该我手写我口
我写下的字就是我平常讲的话
所以那时候才有所谓的心思
也就是诗歌孕育而生
那诗歌刚开始出来的时候
确实他让平常不能写传统诗的也开始写诗了
让不能欣赏传统诗的也能欣赏的
因为他是用口语化去写诗
以前写古诗词的门槛很高
你要有对账
你要用韵
你要有典故
你要有平仄
不是读了几年私塾
你就能写出一首宋词
那是有难度的
所以距离这么远
白话文运动之后确实有好处
所有的文章用白话文书写
书写上的一个便利性跟阅读的障碍消失了
唯一可惜的是音乐跟文字的连接
基本上就被歌词垄断了
因为诗歌或者是新诗再也不适合入月了
白话文运动
文字跟音乐的结合基本上就是歌词垄断了
所以现在呢歌词很讲究韵脚
韵脚的好处是韵脚是听觉的
听觉的歌词会辅助视觉的记忆
在座的各位同学
高中的时候
青春时期个人会抄写歌词
喜欢的歌手拿一个主题曲呀
或是当红的流行歌
就把整首歌词默写下来
其实不是你记忆力好
而是你会唱那首歌了
你是用听觉的节奏感去记住视觉的文字
整首歌很长
A one a two b one b two
可能160几个字甚至200个字
但是你可以写下来
是因为你记住旋律了
你会唱了
基本上你不管脱离学校多久
你一定可以记住几首古典诗词
甚至可以朗诵出来
因为呢他的韵脚
他的平仄辅助了你的听觉
听觉
强化了你的视觉
所以呢你就是把古诗词一字不漏地朗诵下来
但是你要完完整整的背一首新诗很困难
如果这又是散文诗的话
你基本上是背不下来的
训蒙文就是启蒙教育的迅猛文
像弟子规三字经
小朋友六七岁五六岁
他可以一字不漏的从头背到尾哦
因为他字句的对仗
他的韵脚
这种韵脚会让文字行进间有节奏感
有音乐性
有听觉
那他因为听觉去记住视觉的文字
所以以前的古诗词再怎么长
你只要多朗诵几遍
你是背的下来的
但现在的流行音乐就弥补了这个区块
反而是诗歌
也就是新诗
你背不下来
再来就是刚刚讲到那个主观
因为诗人他服务的是自己的情感
所以呢他不需要跟唱片公司开会
不需要沟通
不需要修改
也没有关键字的字入
那我们作词人就很辛苦了
但这种辛苦又有成就感
你是在限制下做最大能力的发挥
这个才是专业
就是说他已经有个约束了
他已经有个旋律的约束了
通常我们这个行业都是先有曲再有词
那各位同学
你就上对课了
为什么词人可以成为一种职业
但是诗人只能是一种身份
你去看文学的排行榜
前几名都是小说
因为它有情节
他有故事线
他有主角
还有剧情
还有跌宕起伏的一个环节
吸你一个章节一个章节的看下去
所以文学排行榜通常都是小说占满了前几名
再还是散文
再是旅游杂记司
通常排名很后面
没那么没那么全面
因为诗人创作的当下
是他主观的情绪及行受的孤独
他的乡愁是他的乡愁
跟我们比较没有太大的关联
但是如果这个乡愁写成了流行音乐
那个影响力就大了
英勇是客观式的创作
而且音乐的辅助煽动性很强
歌手的传唱MV无缘佛爵的打歌
所以歌词写成乡愁的共鸣性很高
那诗写成乡愁的共鸣性就非常的低
因此在这个时空背景下
词人可以变成一种职业类别
但是诗人他可能是杂志社的编辑主编
学校的教授
很少有诗人纯粹只创作诗集
所以呢诗人是一种身份
但词人才会是一种职业
所以各位同学加油